[Music]  utilizing one of the most efficient  natural camouflages on earth this is the  pink winged stick insect  true to its name the pink winged stick  insect does resemble a stick  they have been observed making  repetitive side to side movements  mimicking a stick blowing in the wind  as camouflage is their biggest defense  many stick insects are nocturnal and in  the face of an attack will play dead  some have been seen to even shed a limb  to evade a predator  long and thin these insects range  between 13 and 21 inches in length with  females being longer than the males  little is known about stick insects  making it difficult to declare the  vulnerability of their status in the  wild however this one is endemic to  madagascar and was listed as an  endangered species due to aggressive  deforestation in the area  this is the pink winged stick insect  [Music]  you